he can't get it now Manson for the Avalanche
that's cut off and kept in by Hayes for corenko
right in front knocked down right pad saved by
gorv and we get a whistle Blues get the puck
now mcer to play back for pero delay penalty here
against the Avalanche and a shot by McAn was W and
they get the first power plate tonight who's
win the face off back to Tory K there's kyou
for Thomas Davis parked in front that shot wide
and then Shen under pressure from byon Ab keep
it alive and a centering pass wide open and they
score Manson from the slot and it's one- nothing
Colorado Curtis mcder is a huge man they get on
the for check and big 56 goes right to the front
of the net here they're right in the blue paint
there I don't know if the blues are going to take
a look at this I think they're going to challenge
this call as mcder goes straight into the blue
paint doesn't even try to alter his course and
then Jordan Bennington up you know they generally
give the coaches about you know 45 seconds or so
to make a decision St Louis is challenging the
play to determine if there was goal tender
interference prior to the goal so they are
challenging for goalie interference after coaches
challenged review it was determined that there was
golender interference so a great challenge by Drew
banister to the line scandella brunovich wide open
right in shoots and a glove save by gorgia and
then Robert Thomas trying to work in front pass in
front rolling coock Shen gets it back now Thomas
wide open and a save by gorgia what a shot there
and a great chance for bu davich now KW winds and
fires right on goal saved by gorgia and now Thomas
sets up shot Here Comes shanon he'll drop it off
for Thomas head back to K Thomas again B davic in
the slot K winds shoots it on goal big rebound
Thomas gets it now bu davage handed back in for
Thomas B davage wide open another great chance
and he missed the goal and he's frustrated and
apparently he's all right that's good to see as
now the puck is f in front no one there for the
ABS tipped to the line though kept in and a shot
from the point by the rookie Sam molinsky and a
save by Bennington and McKinnon's pass locked by
Ka and now tchenko trying to go around molinski
the former captain at Cornell signed as a free
agent last year dko in on the four check all over
molinski as four players battle for it kaan
finds it now back to fall and a shot on goal
and a save by gorgia who been sharp early
now the captain trying to Center one that's
off the glove of Taves and the neighbers in
there back to the line brunovich and now for
KA to the net in front Shen was there kept in
by scandella off an avalanche CLA in front and
they it hit wood pressure by the avalan their
best Zone time of the period by across now
Manson shot from the wing rebound they score
chopped that by Johansson and he makes it one
[Music] nothing good look at here's Manson
keeps the puck in shot on net from a bad
angle by drewan the puck drops in front and
Johansson right there just goes up underneath
the arm of Jordan Bennington from the
Plaza entire goalie cam goes right in
that and Thomas quickly on to Center for cyu
return past to Thomas he comes in with speed
to davish gets it back shoots it on goal and
a save by goria here comes m going wide on Ley
he Rings it around the boards the Kinnon gave
it away and a short-handed breakway for Robert
Thomas all alone in on goal he scores
a short-handed goal the to the [Music]
game great pressure by Pavo bich Nathan McKinnon
obviously thinking a teammate is there pass it
right to Robert Thomas who goes forehand backand
bar down it's a beautiful goal so they're good
friends tapped in by Taves now it's bym with
it for the Avalanche back for Taves five to go
in the Captain Miner and a shot from the wing on
goal save by Bennington and no rebound pass up the
middle what a pass to Ley he darts right through
a man and a shot on goal and a save by Korg hold
Paro waiting Nick lety by the way came off the
bench and then he uses that excellent speed this
time to cyu he comes in with speed Kyu shooting
one that goes wide centered by folk and where is
it under the out of gorgia that was close drops
it off to ran and the big spin knocked down there
by Jordan Kyu and now the blues head north with
Paro pass for davit waiting to the net on goal
and a save by gorgia Outlet now for Sammy blle
here is M mckin rather racing in and blade picks
up the loose puck back to fa handcuffed a bit now
a shot on goal rebound some was a shot angles one
off the boards right in front knowing home for the
blues and the ABS on it and here comes McKinnon
to drwan to M ran it right in a shot and Ranon
put it high and that goes out of play he missed
everything this evening but you got to watch a
guy like Nathan McKinnon he gets at good speed
he varies his speeds and that creates gaps and
right there rman snaps the park I believe Jordan
bton may have gotten the piece of this as rning
gets right in tight and right there I think off
the Blocker of Jordan Bennington for Sho in the
four check stole it and now Hayes gets it for St
Louis in this 1-1 game to Toreno wrap around
right in front to the goal crease and no one
was there and now torko again he scored a great
goal in Denver on November 11 Haze for Crew He
Walks right in and a backhander Rolls just wide
maybe off the pad of gorgia cling around back
down to Ranon and it's pass back to ma kale marar
trying to get free runs into perunovic and then a
call here I think on the blues on here as kale
M he's spinning right there his stick is caught
and then he just it's broken maybe that's what
it is playing the puck with a broken stick but
how would you even against Bennington in a 1-1
game m are in and a glove save by benington ends
up with kale Mar here on the penalty shot trying
to go top shelf Jordan Bennington groundz says no
thank you sir and kicks that away with some
Swagger to it Jordan Bennington you know he
wanted this one too he's a big time golender and
he wants those moments y can't knock it down now
s for Hayes and he was checked Avalanche up
the middle ran here he comes with McKinnon he
goes wide McKinnon Cuts in and a save by bennon
opportunity he just see how fast he is here and
it doesn't take much ni Cole Paro is a big tall
guy good speed and still Nathan McKinna manage
to drive here and that little shot right there
now Sun twist and Johanson dig in Johanson wins
it back Taves shoots he scores Taves Let It
Go it might have been tipped and the avalan
actually two to [Applause] one we pick it up here
right from the crash and then taste it certainly
hits something not sure if it's the backside
of the and now K finds it and that goes wide
time running down B navic and that's blocked by
Byam and the Avalanche hang on and win two to one